i would really love to open this with
that song
from the 90s version that got remixed
for the credits of this one but it the
video would get copyright claimed
immediately and i don't like any of the
other videos i had so let's
just roll the credits
[Music]
mortal kombat so
i had really wanted to get this video
out the same day that the
thing uh went live on hbo max which was
friday but i have had
a uh a friday and then into a weekend of
intermittent migraines and a huge work
backlog so that
that didn't happen but i still want to
get my thoughts
out on this now as i mentioned i am a
fan
of the 90s mortal kombat film not mortal
kombat annihilation
we do not speak of such things here but
i grew up on that film
i still like that film i'll still watch
it for fun
and i don't know how much of it is
nostalgia clouding my idea of it but
to me it's a very very good balance of
knowing
precisely how ridiculous it is without
playing the entire premise like it's a
joke and that is not an easy balance to
get and i think that counts for a lot
especially considering that it was a
pg-13 movie of a video game that was far
bloodier than the movie was allowed to
be which was weird
but now we have an r-rated
mortal kombat which is certainly
something that fans of the franchise
have been clamoring for
for a long dang time so
with more time updated effects and
allowing for the gore
that made the series infamous in the
first place
how did the movie turn out
pretty good it's a bit of a mixed bag
it's
funny i was happy with and satisfied by
a lot of it yet by the time it was over
still felt a little bit underwhelmed and
i think that had more to do with some
things that it was
missing but you know what i'm kind of
gonna set that aside
i'll come back to that broadly speaking
on
most measures this is a better
film from any sort of filmmaking
perspective
than the 90s version was it is better
acted
in many areas the effects are way better
the fights are
very well choreographed the nods to the
game are really well integrated i'd say
they're about even on that
actually but it's it's good it's
solid there are certainly some things
that are
more highlights than others and it
definitely opens in a way that is
odd and good but then kind of circles
back around and contributes to
why this doesn't quite
land uh by the time it wraps up
so it opens with a flashback
in the distant past as we watch
effectively
sub-zero versus scorpion now
at this point scorpion isn't really
scorpion yet and
sub-zero hasn't adopted the name yet but
he's still got the ice powers and we do
definitely see
uh the guy who's going to become
scorpion uh show some of the moves that
he's going to be making use of later
and it's cool fight plus you know
i am an unabashed fan of hiroyuki sonata
who plays
scorpion in this so like that's awesome
just having him there he's a he just has
such a great presence on screen he's
phenomenal
and like i said it's a good action scene
not in love with the
cgi blood because i never really care
for cgi blood
that having been said it was noted by a
friend of mine who is more into the
modern games because
admittedly i haven't played a mortal
kombat game since mortal kombat 3
but someone who has been playing it in
the more recent generations did note
that the cgi blood
made it feel more in keeping with the
way blood effects look in the game which
was something that i hadn't considered
whether you think that's basically a
coincidence covering for
cgi blood that isn't good or an actual
selling point i
think there's a valid case to be made
either way i just found that perspective
kind of interesting
but after that we then jump forward to
the present and the character of cole
i'm sorry who yeah and that's the first
thing that's really weird about this
there's a couple of decisions that were
made
that are very strange to me about this
movie the first is that our nominal main
hero
is a guy who is not from the games at
all lewis tan
plays cole young and i want to stress
he's not bad
he's perfectly good in the role and
cole's not even a bad
character but given how expansive the
roster
of mortal kombat characters is it's very
strange to me
that they decided to make one
up instead of repurpose one i suppose
part of that might have to do with the
fact that
what he is doing his role in this story
doesn't really map on cleanly to any of
the
existing characters they they are having
him
sort of discover a legacy and a power
and i suppose you could do that with liu
kang
liu kang does appear but they're not
doing that with him
and if i were to guess the main reason
they're not is because that's the role
lou kane was playing in the 90s and it's
one of the changes that i think
was made largely to make this feel not
like a remake of the 90s version which i
i do get not wanting that feeling
coming off the whole thing but there are
some decisions that were made that very
much
feel borne out of we want to
not overlap with what the 90s version
did and sometimes it's like yeah but you
definitely could have still repurposed
that i feel like just
having it be lou kang and adjusting him
to
adjusting the character to be what cole
is
in this story could have worked fine but
they didn't instead they make up a whole
new character
who i kept waiting this isn't really a
spoiler because i'm basically going to
tell you something that doesn't happen
i kept waiting for coal to
end up becoming transforming turning
into take on the mantle
of a character who is from the games
i mean ultimately my guess was he was
going to basically be the new scorpion
but that doesn't happen nor does any
equivalent of that he's just
coal alright but there's another two
things that feel very much borne out of
a desire to not
repeat the original and i am start gonna
have to start to get into minor spoilers
there will be
bigger spoilers later on but again i'm
largely going to be focusing on
what isn't present and i will talk more
specifically about what
is there a little bit further but i
would consider this minor spoiler
warning territory so
that's your initial warning there it's
very strange to me that the tournament
exists
but is basically not in play the
story never takes on a tournament story
structure
because even though mortal kombat is a
tournament that outworld has one nine
times
and if they win one more time they get
to take over
earth realm cool that's all the same but
here's the thing there's new rules that
only people who bear like sort of this
dragon
mark can um enter into the tournament
now i don't think that's anywhere in the
games
so it's either something introduced
after i stopped playing
or um it's a wrinkle they made up now
that actually works quite well
especially because
one of the interesting wrinkles of that
is if
someone kills somebody who has that mark
it transfers on to them so
that would prevent um you know them
earth realm from just running out of
potential champions
because if someone dies before they get
to the tournament if they were killed
well then whoever killed them that's the
new fighter and obviously the
defeat of this person maybe is a better
fighter anyway so i actually kind of
like that it reminded me a little bit of
um afro samurai and the
like the number two and the number one
headbands i don't have time to explain
that if you know afro samurai you know
what i'm talking about
um but anyways i i like that as an idea
but the thing is what
the plot of this one is is not one more
tournament that earthrealm must
absolutely win
instead it's out world is attempting to
assassinate
all of the viable earth realm champions
before the tournament happens now from a
practical standpoint all of the kinds of
fights that would
be in a tournament are still present
there's still a lot of one-on-one fights
between these characters but the
structure of a tournament is
absolutely absent it's not there at all
which makes the whole thing feel a
little bit disjointed especially because
we spend
a chunk of the first bit dealing with
effectively training for the tournament
that never happens again the fights that
would have been in the tournament happen
i don't know maybe i'm just too attached
to that structure and that
building of anticipation where we've had
a fight and now
you know there's going to be some time
in between and there's the anxiousness
and the tension building to the next
fight i kind of
i wanted that and it's not here and the
other thing
uh that because i do believe that that
was something imposed partly to
not feel like the 90s movie because the
90s movie very much fits a tournament
film structure
narratively i think the other thing i
did was basically not have shang tsung
be the end boss now he's present
and this is actually one of the few
things that i will say
unequivocably the shang tsum from the
90s version
was better all due respect to chen han
kerry hiroyuki tagawa
completely blows them out of the water
as shang tsung but it doesn't matter as
much as you would think because as i
said shang tsung is not the end
boss which is one of the things about
this that makes it
feel a little bit underwhelming by the
end
which is that it feels like it
hasn't had a proper resolution
really let me get some more uh
unapologetic praise out of the way
josh lawson who plays kano
oh my god he is amazing he is so
much fun as kano
performance wise in terms of just
bringing a
wonderful energy to the thing he's
terrific
absolutely love him performance
highlight of the movie nobody else is
actually really bad
um but nobody else gives a performance
as memorable
as his ho that's great
props though as well to make brooks who
plays jax
he he looked like he was having a lot of
fun too and i do also really want to
bring some praise
to the ice effects on sub-zero they were
really interestingly done they looked
painful to be caught in the wake of and
they were just
actually they kind of even looked
painful for him to use he seemed unfazed
by it but like
you'd see the ice start to form in the
tips of his fingers and his hand looked
frostbitten
ah like it was cool it was kind of
unsettling in a very cool way but now i
kind of got to get into
um the stuff where it kind of falls down
a little bit towards the end
and it's gonna be a little bit difficult
to explain this but this is your final
spoiler warning
i am going to talk about stuff that goes
on uh at the end here
so as i said shang tsung is not the end
about shang tsun actually doesn't really
have a proper fight with anybody
instead the final fight is between
well it's a three-way fight it is
sub-zero
versus resurrected scorpion
and cole young and
what's weird about this is while
sub-zero has been a presence
since the beginning and a threat since
the beginning
he is not in any way orchestrating or
even
really the right hand of
shang tsung in this he doesn't
feel like an appropriate final boss
the whole climax pivoting on him it like
it feels like a mid-boss
it doesn't even really have that feeling
of you know
taking on you know a darth vader knowing
there's a palpatine later on we're not
even taking on the darth vader we're
we're taking on i don't know captain
phasma
feels a bit more like i'm i i don't know
if
i'm mixing up my star wars timeline to
get that analogy across and i don't even
know
if it works but knowing that sub-zero
wasn't behind anything and not
rooting uh enough really nobody other
than
scorpion who spends the bulk of the
movie dead
has a personal beef with him so it
doesn't work as a
as an emotional climax either they try
to have it be
one for coal because he's protecting his
family but he's protecting his family
from
a bunch of fighters you know sub-zero is
certainly a threat and he's
taken his family but like he's he also
fought goro
in relation to that as well so it's not
it's not feeling
personal in the way that it did for
scorpion but because scorpion hasn't
been around it's harder to be invested
in him fighting sub-zero
that said it's a good fight it's a very
cool fight all the fights are
and some of the gore as even though i
kind of complained a little bit
about the about the cgi blood some of
the gore is like oh
dang okay and they do like flat out
grant some fatalities
um kung lao has a very cool fatality jax
uses it has his classic
uh which is very cool i think
ultimately the thing holding this back
is the way that it sort of trips over
itself
trying to distinguish itself from
the 90s version and honestly i think the
use
of that song
might even be the best way to sum that
up
because it was a question that
um you know fans had is that song going
to be around
and eventually the makers did say oh yes
we're using that song don't worry and i
kept waiting for it to kick in during
the movie
it doesn't it goes over the end credits
and i think what's telling about that is
i can't guarantee that this is the case
but it makes it feel very much like they
didn't
want to use the song if they'd wanted to
use the song
it would have been present in the film
itself during its proper run time
putting it over the credits is basically
throwing the fans a bone because they
knew the fans wanted it but if the
makers have wanted it to be there it
would have been more tightly integrated
into the thing itself
and that feeling that that leaves me
with that feeling of
we didn't want to have this thing from
the 90s
is kind of permeating the whole film
now i don't want to say that it's a bad
thing to try and distinguish your
product from something that came before
especially if it's got the same dang
title
but given that what most fans wanted was
something not dissimilar to that film
that maybe took things
a little more seriously a little less
joking and a heck of a lot more violent
it tries to distinguish itself so much
that i feel like a lot of its problems
wouldn't be there if it just swallowed
the fact that it's going to be
structurally a bit like the 90s version
i think the film would have been more
fun
having the tournament structure having
shang tsung be more of a presence having
the fight end with him
not having coal now there's still plenty
of stuff that you
can do and that the film does do to
distinguish it it has
other characters it brings in kung lao
who is not a presence
in that 90s version what it does with
kano completely different
and wonderful and incredibly memorable
it brings in cabal it gives jack
something to do which you didn't get to
do until
that movie that i said we don't speak of
here so like there's enough here to
people are not going to mistake it for a
remake but for some reason they felt the
need to do all this other stuff to make
it feel even less like that film
which also results in a bloated run time
it this thing runs
about an hour 50 minutes which is longer
than it needs
but part of the reason it needs the
extra time is to cover
the ways in which the story is different
because the original again had an
incredibly straightforward structure
here's the tournament here's the stakes
get them fighting
this requires a lot more explanation but
it only requires more explanation
because you rejected the simplicity of
the tournament setup
so as much as i did have fun with this
movie and we'll praise
certain aspects of it like the fights
like
josh lawson as kano i still came away
ultimately feeling like
you would have been a better film if you
hadn't been so worried about
not looking like the 90s version
that's just kind of where i ended up
but what did you think about it have you
seen mortal kombat hope so
you got through the spoiler parts
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
if i'm very lucky there will be a link
to my patreon
up over there i think i might figure out
how to get that working again we'll see
there are
there's rewards at every tier including
a patreon specific discord
and of course names in the credits as
you are now currently seeing
give it a look it's my living it's what
keeps this whole things going but also
no pressure the usual stuff
of like share subscribe helps me out as
well but don't worry about that either
because at the end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
bye